hope you've got your happy face on cuz
Joker is here to bring a little maniacal
mirth to the gritty mean streets of
Gotham joaquin phoenix undeniably the
star but he's joined by an impressive
supporting cast and yes you've
absolutely seen most of their faces
before that perfectly coiffed heiress on
the verge of iconic status in its own
right and her name is undeniably fun to
say but it's a cbiit seemingly
effortless charisma and incisive
approach to her characters that helped
set her apart that combination of
attributes undoubtedly helped drive
director Todd Phillips to cast the
gifted actor as Arthur flex crappy
neighbor and romantic interest Sophie in
Joker though beats track record of
holding her own in the company of
serious actors didn't hurt that
particular skill has been well on
display throughout beat still young
Korea if you're wondering where you've
seen over four beats featured
prominently in the brewery brother
storyline of Joe Swanberg egregiously
underrated Netflix anthology series easy
she's also played van a no-nonsense baby
mama to donald Glover's earn on the
critically adored FX drama d Atlanta
it's most likely however that you saw
beats hamming it up as Domino aka the
luckiest woman alive opposite Ryan
Reynolds foul-mouthed antihero in
Deadpool to meet domina what's your
stick I'm lucky luck isn't a superpower
yes it is no isn't Beats is set to
reprise that scene-stealing role in the
still developing Deadpool spin-off
x-force but if you don't want to wait
that long you can currently see her in
Steven Soderbergh's Netflix drama high
flying bird and the creepy new streamer
wounds as Joker spends more than a
little bit of time examining the
struggles of life and stand-up comedy it
seems fitting that Marc Maron would
feature prominently in the narrative he
has after all spend the bulk of his
professional life making a name for
himself as one of the more insightful
comedians around it's also a safe bet
his hard earned success eventually led
him into direct contact with sleazy
late-night-tv producers at the one he
plays in Joker
Ted Marco of course he infamously
cantankerous comic has stretched his
talents far beyond the stand-up stage of
lates and made a proper actor of himself
Moroni stolen scenes and supporting
roles on comedic series like girls and
he even managed to score his own show
IFC's Marin most recently Marin has
gotten cozy with Netflix for a
brilliantly SERO comic turn as a
floundering graphic novelist in Joe
Swanberg easy and
nearly stolen the entire show as a faded
b-movie director in the streaming
giant's lauded Lady Restless series glow
if you're wondering where you've seen
him on the big screen Maron delivered a
memorable cameo in 2016 s comic fast
Mike and Dave need wedding dates those
savvy sinner files may also know him as
a angry promoter who tried to lock the
gates on Stillwater in Cameron Crowe's
mm masterpiece almost famous over the
past couple of decades frances conroy
has essentially become a career mother
on big screens and small she's also
managed to turn every mom she's played
into cunningly complex characters you
can't stop watching as such Conroy was
sort of a perfect fit to portray Arthur
flexpa ragged mother penny while Conroy
is sure to bring some serious traumatic
energy to the relentless bleak world of
Todd Phillips Joker every performance in
the movie will almost certainly be
overshadowed by the work of star walk in
Phoenix that's okay because even if
frances conroy isn't stealing the show
in Joker
she's already stolen our hearts as a
passionate lead low-key matriarch of the
Fisher clan in HBO's life death and
everything in between drama Six Feet
Under
if you somehow manage to miss Conroy's
work on that series it's entirely
possible you recognize her from her work
as Alex and Valerie successively fight
Imam in Jason motorman's tragically
overlooked hulu series casual though
it's far more likely you know her as
Barney's mom Loretta from How I Met Your
Mother and if you somehow not seen
Conroy in any of those series you should
absolutely know her from her multiple
roles in Ryan Murphy's horror anthology
American Horror Story or perhaps from
her appearance and Hulu Stephen King
centric series Castle Rock bang shot I
told the dear retired we're going to
find out once it's wrong he's got knees
hmm we suppose is acceptable that most
viewers likely don't know Shaye Wiggins
name but in reality you should be far
more familiar with Wiggum as he's one of
the preeminent character actors in
Hollywood
while his work as Detective Burke and
Joker doesn't seem to require much
stretching for Wiggum he's played many
many detective types over the years the
actor still manages to put his own
peculiar stamp on a character that
otherwise might have felt very stuck
that source of Wickham's mo for the
record if you don't yet recognize his
name he's made a career of bringing
uncommon death to fringe characters in
all manner of film and television
projects since breaking through in the
early 2000s and it's all but impossible
you haven't seen it
faced before in fact you've probably
seen it a dozen times or so as the actor
has brought us formidable presence to
Indy gems like Joel Schumacher's
Tigerland David Gordon greens or the
real girls and Jeff Nichols takes
shelter
he's also appeared in lauded TV series
like Boardwalk Empire
agent Carter Fargo true detective vice
principals and homecoming all while
lending his talent to high-profile fare
like The Fast and Furious franchise the
wolf of Wall Street American hustle Kong
Skull Island and first man so yeah if
you don't know Shea Whigham name now's
the time to learn it on the subjects are
faces you no doubt recognize but names
you may not know you should probably go
ahead and learn by anti we Henry's name
as well Henry has been busy busy busy of
late earning solid reviews for his work
in film projects like if Peel Street
could talk person to person hotel
Artemus white boy wreck and widows not
to mention he also contributed his voice
a 20-18 oscar-winning hit spider-man
into the spider-verse
Henry also appeared in critically hailed
TV series like Boardwalk Empire the
knick Vice Principals this is us room
104 and Bojack horseman of course Bryan
Tyree Henry is undeniably best known for
his role as hustling hip hop star in the
making Alfred paperboy miles in Donald
Glover hilarious and often soul-crushing
FX series Atlanta and if you haven't
seen Hermes work in Atlanta would urge
you to go watch the season 2 episode
woods immediately full weight your waist
in tan and the only people who get tired
are dead and if you did I'm gonna take
them shoes up all the supporting
characters that have come and gone in
the Batman Cinematic Universe few of
them have been more important than
Thomas Wayne it stands to reason that
the actor who landed the role of the
Dark Knight study would need to be more
than capable of bringing a certain
degree of gravitas to the character as
portrayed in Joker the character
required a bit of duplicitous well as
the would-be male Wayne may have more to
do with fracturing the psyche of the
burgeoning Joker than one would think
Phillips and his casting director
clearly understood that when they cast
veteran character actor Bret Cullen as
Thomas Wayne Collins career has seen
countless TV appearances and everything
from The Thorn Birds for the West Wing
from Friday Night Lights to true
detective that's not even mentioning a
steady stream of big screen ventures
which includes Wyatt
herb Apollo 13 national security Ghost
Rider and the Dark Knight Rises before
he even reaches his tenth birthday
youngster Dante Pereira Olsen is about
to claim a third role as a younger
version of an adult character
needless to say young Bruce Wayne is the
actor's biggest role yet even if he
doesn't actually get to portray the
Batman and Joker if you're wondering
what the other two roles were you should
know that prior to Joker Ferrera Olsen's
most notable the youngster and so
appearance was as a younger version of
the actor who plays a Joker himself yep
but that was dante pereira olsen playing
the young version of Joaquin Phoenix's
Joe in 2018 s harrowing drama you were
never really here he also lent his voice
to the young version of Jason
Schwartzman s Bradford sharp and the
Amazon series Mozart in the jungle and
that just so happens that Joker is
hardly Pereira Olsen's first foray into
the superhero genre as he's already
logged time in Netflix's Jessica Jones
and can be seen as a youngest Kara
Moochie in sci-fi adaptational Grant
Morrison's happy regarding the
manservant who actually raised the
future Batman in the tragic absence of
Thomas and Martha Wayne Alfred
Pennyworth may well be the single most
important figure in the long tortured
history of The Dark Knight who isn't
actually a Wayne it also makes his
presence in Joker as big a deal as that
as young Bruce or Thomas
luckily Douglas Hajus a source of actor
who can bring some serious weight to any
role though he's only recently popped up
on American viewers radar the British
SAS peon has been acting in various
projects for decades now if you're
wondering why Joker's Alfred look so
familiar it's likely because you saw him
trading lines of Hugh Laurie tom
hiddleston elizabeth debicki and Olivia
Colman in 2016 AMC miniseries the night
manager or you saw him facing off
against Jennifer Lawrence in the spy
thriller red Sparrow of course black
mirror fans will almost certainly
recognize Hajus Rallo Haynes the sleaze
peddling proprietor of the titular
roadside attraction in the black Museum
episode how the folks just rushed behind
the curtain hardly even high above this
stuff and then it's a bunch of 1 star
ratings on trip before you know it if
you only remember two faces and/or names
from this list you should definitely
remember those of zazzy beats and Bryant
IV Henry because they're about to become
two of the most sought-after talents in
Tinseltown
if you have room for a third name you
could do a lot worse than noting Bill
camps
he's been one of the most consist
overlook talents and films and TV for a
couple of decades now and his supporting
role is detective Garrity in Joker is
not likely to raise his profile very
much
that being said would be surprised if
you didn't recognize comes face because
he's also been one of the most prolific
supporting actors around in recent years
and even though his dynamite character
workers frequently overlooked his face
has remained quite visible as the way
you've seen Bill come before he's
appeared in films like rounders
reservation Road and Public Enemies but
had a bit of a breakout year in 2012
delivering memorable turns on the
unnerving indie drama compliance and
playing a Tassili lawman opposite Tom
Hardy Charlotte buff and Jessica
Chastain in lawless camp has been
keeping busy since turning up an awards
friendly fare like Lincoln 12 years of
slave and the killing of a sacred deer
he's also scored raves for a small
screen work on damages the night of
Boardwalk Empire and the leftovers you
can count the perpetually deadpan
performer Josh price as one of the most
after overlooked talents in the film
industry
you could also count us as excited about
pretty much any film pice lenses talents
too because he always manages to bring
an odd mix of intellect and anxious
energy to any movie he's in it should
also come a sort of an anti spoiler
alert then that pice brings the same
off-kilter energy to his role as a
pseudos nihilistic manager who runs
Arthur flex rundown Hotel and Joker that
oddball outsider energy shows through in
virtually every performance he's
delivered since his first credited
appearance on The Cosby Show that
includes his work in Star Trek at Deep
Space 9 Sex in the City a civil action
scream 3 a beautiful mind The Sopranos
Adventureland Laura Nora maniac and much
much more but if you want to see Josh
Pais at his best
you're gonna want to check him out and
then Shelton's pitch-perfect 2013 indie
flick touchy feely which also features
stellar work from Rosemarie DeWitt Ellen
Page and scoot mcnairy
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and to
the bail so you don't miss a single one
[Music]